testes testes one two
three
it's um there it is it's it's just like
nine o'clock it's nine o'clock it's nine
a.m it is nine a.m isn't it and that
when what do we agree on a time today
yeah i believe we said 9 00 am megan did
we say 9 00 a.m
nine and i'm here i'm sitting in my
chair yeah i've got a chair uh i'm not
buying my chair yeah and yet
this chair is um
this chair's empty yeah um
well now this is the first
edition of the video
podcast yeah isn't this exciting uh
this room is uh
awful yeah
yeah we're gonna have to learn it's a
little character-less
although i'm noticing in your shot glenn
you see
my giant belly
that's kind of challenging my belly no
no behind you oh oh oh oh oh i thought
you meant like the one that you're
sporting now no no no no well that's
underwater
you know i was thinking about that well
first of all i want to say that one of
the things i find very funny about this
is like
we're no longer allowed to talk to each
other right because every time i start
to tell you something yeah you're like
save it for the podcast
for the podcast
um now is that because uh uh
we think we're that interesting no no i
think it's that we're afraid we're gonna
run out of things to talk about oh yeah
i know you're absolutely right so just
anything and yeah just talk about
anything for example
charlie not being here a missing man a
missing man is actually very interesting
yes
now i am concerned
um i am concerned for
how interesting the podcast is going to
be without charlie if you think about
the show itself mm-hmm
if we didn't have charlie now don't tell
him this well he already knows no no no
no no no no no he know but he yeah but
that's the thing he's he he doesn't need
to hear that because he's he already
knows it and it's a whole thing without
charlie showed up it didn't really work
you know what i mean yeah probably
wouldn't have gotten to season 15
without charlie
makes me think we should wait on the
podcast but no no no we this is the
tradition if you don't show up on time
you you you lose yeah you lose so here
we go you snooze you lose now let's get
into it rob um i'm seeing a cane glenn i
would say
this is a king qualifies a cane okay
now this is my first day off uh crutches
and i got myself in a shoe instead of a
boot
i tore some ligaments in my foot
um but i was
i was so adamant on being on time for
this podcast i was supposed to get a
ride here and i was supposed to get
picked up
and
um the r now the the person who was
driving me was coming from the same area
of town that charlie is
so i think there's some pretty bad
traffic but that's no excuse because
traffic in la how noble that's a given
it's a given yeah so uh he wasn't
getting there on time i text him i said
where are you where are you where are
you i'll get there i'll get there i said
i can't risk being late for this podcast
charlie actually texted us
and said hey i might be a little bit
late you said that won't matter that
won't matter i said this text won't
matter this text won't matter but then
after i sent it i was still sitting in
my driveway waiting for my ride and then
i thought oh [ __ ] now i've thrown a
gauntlet down that's right and now my
foot that's all [ __ ] up is my right
foot that's right it's you're driving a
driving foot yeah that's everyone's
driving yeah oh yes
[Laughter]
yeah it's unless you
i hope
well unless you're driving on vacation
it's both i guess but if you're driving
wet or if you drive a manual then it's
uh both feet is it not yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's right
yeah okay so uh either way your left
foot is generally not you're driving
quick that's your point um but i thought
i gotta
now i've thrown the gauntlet down i
gotta i just gotta get in the car and go
yeah and so i did and as i did my ride
was passing me but like literally we
just passed each other and i lost guys
with him and he knew
what a picture you guys like just the
the
the like turn as you guys he was driving
so fast that like he almost hit like hit
me and like
like weaved out of the way okay so
basically what we're learning today is
you didn't want to risk being late for
the podcast so that so that the same
thing that we're doing to charlie right
now wouldn't happen to you yes but you
were willing to risk your life and
brian's brian's life
and to get here on time
yes there was no way that i was going to
be late for this podcast yeah
well here we are this is the video
portion ah you know it's it is it is
like i now it's like
when someone has been late and i haven't
been late yet which is crazy because i
traditionally have used to be always be
of all of us the latest
um but now we're six minutes in and we
gotta start talking about the episode i
think
yeah unless you got some other [ __ ] to
talk about you know what i think we
should talk about what is this office
when this is the video this is is this
our set
this is a piece of [ __ ] yeah we can't do
this we we can't do this uh we're gonna
step it up guys this is behind me
uh oh well there's mag though everybody
can see meg yeah
oh no she had oh she hid come on megan
well she finally has a microphone by the
way
oh yes i said i didn't see that before
okay
now now to be clear listener is it on if
everybody assumes that our um our goal
in this podcast was to silence women
by not giving them a microphone you are
sorely mistaken we have been begging meg
to get on mike from day one and all you
can hear is her laughter in the
background now we feed off of her
laughter that's true i might live for it
at this point
um yeah
but now we can actually see well sort of
she's sneaking behind the camera but
anyway that's meg that's meg can i ask
you a question so
i when i realized that we were filming
this one well not when i realized it but
when i really thought about it the
reality of it i was like
oh [ __ ] like
i now have to like worry about my hair
yeah you know i gotta make sure i get
enough sleep because we don't have like
hair and makeup you know what i mean
it's not like a tv show where you have
hair and makeup
although maybe we should
well we should consider we should
consider it by the way people watch
podcasts yeah that's right that's why
we're doing this yeah news to me that's
why we're doing this um well uh listener
watcher
um
we apologize for our faces uh well
actually sorry i apologize for my face
rob
made me feel good about his face i i
think the problem is for me and we
talked about this also on the podcast is
like
even though you guys don't see me this
way like i feel like my eyes are the
thing is is like whenever i post
anything on instagram right
there's inevitably like a handful of
people that are always like whoa you
look stoned man and i'm like no god
that's just my face
that's just my eyes like i just have
tired looking eyes all the time and
people are like oh dude you must be
stoned all the time and i'm not
i'm not that's just how my eyes look
well i'm looking at you now and i'm not
too bad no they're not too bad i can i
can see yeah i guess but i wouldn't have
thought
he just sort of strolls in whenever he
feels like it
took me an hour from my kid's school to
get here yeah unreasonable unreasonable
unreasonable it's live
take a good look around this office this
is the last time i moved
we'll find a new spot we'll find a new
spot
do you want to express your feelings
right now on the podcast
it's not so much about the traffic that
i'm upset with it's it's knowing
the joy that you guys are going to get
out of beating me here
on the first video portion of the
podcast it was an empty chair just
sitting there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of great though yeah sure it's
kind of great no but we're the same way
but both of us risked our lives to get
here on time today basically like
i didn't rob was talking about how you
know brian was supposed to pick him up
and because of his ankle he's not
supposed to be driving like that but i
told him i have torn ligaments but brian
was running late so he took a risk and
decided to drive with a busted ankle
well now we're rehashing stories that
the audience has already heard
by the way can i speaking of rehashing
stories pretty boring stories without me
here right i would imagine pretty boring
talking about you're definitely better
and we also discussed not saying it to
you because you would react that way
exactly
anyway
no what we said was well he knows that
already so we don't need to rehash it
and then here we go
i don't feel the same about either one
of you it's not a it's not just a me
thing it's the chemistry of the three of
us the dynamic baby but i was driving
over here being like if i quit if i quit
the podcast
you know if they were like no we're
working in this office no matter what
yeah
we keep going you'd still have to pay me
you wouldn't yeah be a whole sticky
legal thing for you it would just yeah
it would just make more sense to just
baby and it wouldn't be as much fun it
would not be as much it definitely
wouldn't be as much fun jiggly ass
cheering
yeah pretty jiggly if this is this a
janky office in a janky part of town rob
apple has money get a good office we're
in the mythic quest offices right now um
and uh again i i think that this is like
maybe maybe this is interesting for the
viewer now and also the listeners people
think that like uh production offices or
writer's offices or are nice and they're
not they're pieces of [ __ ] some of them
are
yeah some of them why you know like the
the long running shows uh the super long
running shows like it's always sunny in
philadelphia usually have like a set
office that's like super decorated and
stuff like that we never do that we just
go from office to office and it usually
looks like this but i feel like it's
appropriate for the writing of our show
uh but i do enjoy like for example
somebody at one point had this wall
painted right yeah and then and then and
then each production came it was
probably some company that you know did
marketing why did they do that what was
the inspiration behind that that's awful
it was probably like a candle company or
something don't you think like
yeah or something yeah
can i just bring something up also like
speak cause but you were talking about
rehashing old stories now i've gotten
some feedback from a few people from a
lot of people on my socials and then
very specific feedback
from heath cullen's wife emma who also
has a podcast and is a and a very
intelligent woman rob her one note was
well she said
well it was it was you know you guys eat
the microphone you guys know he was he
got rid of the pop card he's gonna
he's gonna he's definitely gonna suck it
at some point he's gonna gag on that
i love the cameras i know it's good for
the podcast but
i know i just like i don't either makes
you a little bit more self-conscious
maybe we'll get used to it is there a
three shot meg oh there is a three shot
yeah anyway uh emma's note was sorry
amazon
um you know every time we go to tell a
story that that rob has heard he points
out i've heard this story yes and what
we haven't put in the podcast is our
response to that which is these stories
aren't for you rob no they're for the
listener who's never heard the [ __ ]
stories okay emma yeah but okay emma let
me point something out and she's like
why is rob constantly becoming hilarious
that we don't remember that which is
totally true
by the way there was a there was an
email this morning that you remembered
god bless your brain man i i want a
little bit of whatever you got going on
there that [ __ ] drove me crazy when i
read that last what
well there was an email from our manager
about someone who wanted to to
write something about the show and he
was like does this person have uh
permission to legally write this i think
it was a book because fx wants to ask
them about it because that's that's the
email saying yeah fx wants to go and ask
them and
i saw the email read the link goes uh
i've never heard of this thing you felt
the same way and rob's like you guys not
only have you all heard it we were there
was an email about it before and once
you said that you're absolutely right
man did you go back i don't know if you
guys went back and looked for but i saw
that actually i said robert whatever's
that means
the point is this the point is this i
recognize that the stories are for the
listener okay but you but the way that
you're telling oftentimes you're telling
us yes because we know how to present a
story and the story is like oh you guys
i gotta tell you this right not like
we're talking to each other in the
podcast you [ __ ] i recognize that but
the thing that i find amazing is that
you are hearing it for the first time
in the moment you know what an actor
does
he pretends that he's hearing something
for the first time this is real life
and you think this isn't a performance
part of the
department listening back to them
sometimes it is a performance for you
sometimes
sometimes it's real life and sometimes
if that camera's rolling and that mic is
hot
i'm performing
okay just know that
the cameras i feel like spielberg is
going to be too shy to pop in because of
the cameras some of our callers
i don't know we can always cut to black
when he walks in yeah well because you
know he doesn't he doesn't feel
comfortable being recorded is that true
he loves being behind the camera
clearly so if he walks in we cut to
black right here we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
i definitely don't want to lose it
because he's he he works around here and
he likes swinging by every once in a
while and i definitely don't want him to
feel uncomfortable swinging by because
he's stephen spielberg you want to have
him on the show yeah it's amazing yes he
wants to come on the show we but we
gotta yeah and make sure the door's open
same thing with uh with brad pitt you
know what i mean he's a walk into the
podcast because he has an open
invitation to join the podcast anytime
he wants and uh we don't want him
feeling like oh i'm not in full hair and
makeup my i haven't frosted my tips or
whatever he's doing with his hair this
week you know by the way can we talk
about this why is it i can see pictures
of brad pitt with super short hair
right and then the next week
he can have long hair in a ponytail
it might pictures can be taken yeah the
thing about pictures no no no no no no
no no no no no no i brought this up no i
saw it is he holding a newspaper up with
the date on it
how long do you think it would take you
to grow your hair to the point where you
could have a a real ponytail not a
little nubbin
but an actual ponytail am i brad pitt
35 in this scenario you are that guy the
man can do anything yeah
you're saying brad pitt is so awesome
that he can grow his hair at a rate
has he ever let you know anyone couldn't
if anyone could come on brad pitt yeah
well
i don't know if i should tell pictures
from a movie like you know like maybe
one is him out at lunch and then he's
doing a movie where he has long hair so
they have like an extension in or
whatever like you know you don't know
about these photos somebody did somebody
told me once that he was on a red carpet
with brad pitt where he had a ponytail
and the ponytail fell off
[Applause]
you're the one asking about how to go
sorry
we're on camera now what is that
it's just coffee it's cold brew i like
cold brew it looks green it looks green
does it look green hold it up to the
camera oh you know what god you guys my
kids sometimes use these glasses and
they put their like they put their
paints in it and stuff oh [ __ ]
that's very unusual
what do you think that might be it
well it's green well we wash them
we wash them they're kids safe paints
you're fine you're fine you're fine it's
just live on the edge for once um um i
mean your character drinks paint all the
time yeah but that's a character and
it's not really paint and it's and he'd
be dead if he were a real person
i don't know should we talk about the
episode the gang runs for office i'm
excited charlie's here though i think
the podcast is is better with charlie i
think it's fine
that he's here i think it's fine i'd say
it's definitely better all right
i love you
i love you now you
arm he doesn't like to be touched
it was a combination of people okay okay
all right where are you going let's get
into that where's that hand gonna go
where's that headed you're gonna try to
give me a noogie
oh no good luck man
good luck bro good luck dude i don't
want to take that go ahead and try
[Music]
now can we talk about the episode or
well yes you wanted to keep stalling
should we do it well yeah can i can i
admit something oh god yeah go ahead and
watch it i don't want to make this about
me um but but i
so here's the thing you forgot to watch
it i i no i didn't forget i didn't
forget i um
and i'm going to take full
responsibility because i thought maybe i
could just
lie
and just pretend and just go along with
it but then i thought man i gave charlie
so much [ __ ] for being late and i knew i
was going to and we did and um
and now i feel really guilty and i'm
just going to be dead honest with you i
didn't watch the episode and it's not
because i didn't want to but i have a
million reasons they're just gonna sound
like excuses it kind of blows this whole
thing man like why did i uh drive
through an hour of traffic if uh to talk
about uh you know i guess we'll talk
about other stuff or maybe glen and i
can refresh your memory you have a
perfect memory anyway you can probably
remember every aspect of it well listen
why don't we call emma why don't we have
emma come
emma come talk to us maybe she could
give us some give me some notes on how i
should approach the podcast well what
she doesn't want you doing is uh like
when somebody starts to tell an
interesting story basically shutting
them down
yes and
you're saying yes and instead of
no why
you know the old improv thing is yeah
it's yes and not no why are you
not not on our show our show is not a
yes
no [ __ ] you
that is true yeah well i actually
remember charlie very early on maybe
season one
um i've never taken an improv class and
i remember like trying to keep up with
the improv and for some reason my
instinct would be like season one
charlie would say something really funny
and i'd be like no you didn't really do
that or no that didn't really happen or
whatever and i remember you pulling me
aside and being like hey man just like
fyi
like you kind of gotta go with it
because if if you say no then like the
scene stops right i was like oh [ __ ]
he's right again yeah all right i'm
gonna start doing i'm gonna start doing
that and apparently that's like a basic
tenet of yes and yes of course
a lot of people don't know this but like
that is that that is like i think
and i never took an improv class either
but like i think that is the number one
rule in improv is that
you're supposed to you know take
whatever because improv you know you
don't know what the other person's gonna
say like the second you stop it and say
no the whole thing ends right so you
gotta say yes and and bill so the idea
is to build upon what the other person's
imagination speaking of that's a there's
a good segue actually into this episode
that we should talk about and i think
probably it's a really funny episode
there's a ton of funny stuff
that we didn't continue doing like where
we stay with the
union guys and they're like yeah you
know they call us nerds or we kind of
end with the cops being somewhat
heightened you know or they like looking
at the camera and they say like that's
politics
but
um
the improv
that glenn is doing where he's reading
my speech
i don't know if you recall this but the
the props guy
whoever it was i don't remember who was
that season but
and it might not have been the head
prosperous might have just been like the
props guy's assistant wrote
just something on a piece of paper like
a bad speech
the joke was that you just couldn't read
it didn't make sense there was no actual
reading of it that we scripted
and it's so damn funny
what he wrote and your reaction to it
that it's a good example of yes and
where it's like
i don't know you just have to be looking
for those moments and then just run with
them right well because it wasn't uh it
wasn't scripted
i believe as scripted it was you saying
just read the speech i wrote and me
saying i'm not going to read i'm not
going to read the speech yes and then
the scene i think just ended with that
yeah like i'm not doing this
i'm not reading this it doesn't make any
sense and then i think we just did one
where it was like and basically i mean
a lot of the words that i say
were written on that piece of paper it's
just that it was it was a more coherent
speech it was a bad speech but it was
coherent and i made it as incoherent as
possible it's weird though that people
find that so funny because i don't ever
i've never found that funny i i've never
really understood words so much as your
reaction to them you're like yeah like
the fact that you're reading you can't
believe that you're reading such bad
benefits i just remember very distinctly
the speech ending with and so do
yeah is that the final one but there's
no end it's just sodu
so do oh yeah i thought it was so do as
well but i think maybe the blooper is
then so do
well
what's in that i also remember being
behind the monitors for that and charlie
is laughing hysterically he's laughing
in this yeah we didn't have any other
options
sometimes look
sometimes i laugh well glenn we've
established that you are the host of the
show could you what should we do next um
well i so so here this is a little
awkward or maybe it isn't i don't know i
i always write notes on my phone when i
watch the episode right like if i have
questions i want to ask you guys or
things i want to talk about or whatever
it looks like i'm just looking at my
phone in the in the video but
you know just know
uh listener watcher
watcher you [ __ ] creep
uh that when i'm looking at my phone
that's great it's insulting
the audience apparently half the
audience watches the podcast and you've
just called them all creeps
i did have a question for you guys did
you guys have uh garbage pail kids when
you were when you were kids
yeah there was one specific kid who
turned me on to them and he had and he
lived like along with his dad and his
dad was a fisherman so he's on the water
all the time so basically this kid was
just like on his own it's just with his
garbage ball case yeah and and he had a
bunch of really good [ __ ] because i you
know i think it's one of those
situations where like the dad feels bad
that like he's just never there and the
mom's not in the picture so he's just
like here's like that like redmond the
robot robot he had that robot oh he had
friends those were his friends
yeah the garbage bill kids and the robot
were his friends yeah and he had garbage
bill kids and he turned me onto the
garbage bill kids and i was like these
are the greatest thing ever
for like a month yes and then you're
like yeah i'm over there the gum's real
dry
yeah is there gum i never had any i had
friends who had them and i never got
them myself but i did enjoy it there's
like a real dry sometimes flaky gum
falls apart like in the baseball card
yeah
yeah
i was definitely into them i love i love
that did you have a collection we were
all in the sweet spot yeah
yeah we were in the sweet spot weren't
we yeah i talked to baseball cards too
oh you did yeah do you ever get any good
ones
yeah but then you know
that was some [ __ ] like where you'd
get the magazine and it would tell you
how much each card was worth yeah and
then you'd be like all right i got the
ken griffey rookie card and i'm gonna
and it says it's worth 20 bucks i'm
gonna go to the store
and they're gonna give me 20 bucks for
it because it says it says that's what
it's worth in the book and then you go
to the comic books store and they'd be
like i'll give you
like that's what we sell it for yeah
that's where you sell on shop right
right and i honestly think that that is
what eventually like collapsed that
entire market because people were like
well [ __ ] it if you're not
you're selling it to me for that but
you're not buying it back right and then
that was it so until recently when it
came back did it come back oh yeah i i
got myself ricky henderson rookie nice
training
my buddy carl traded it to me for a
couple of couple things we discussed
this before but i'm sorry i'm ricky was
my favorite player he was my favorite
player yeah that's i just said we've
discussed this before no but i know but
that's acknowledging that we've
discussed about that and by the way do
your thing i i don't even worry about it
people ricky henderson thanks for your
permission dad
ricky from
ricky henderson little known fact ricky
henderson or maybe this is a widely
known fact i don't know speaks of
himself
in the third person
so ricky does this and ricky does that
yeah ricky doesn't do this ricky does
that ricky wants that
ricky will be there
what is that is that when you become so
like famous or popular or loved that you
also start separating yourself from like
separating your
persona from the real you and so you
start referring to yourself in the third
person when you have the stolen base
record you're like normal things don't
apply to me anymore i gotta i gotta
heighten this you know yeah ricky ricky
gonna start doing this and ricky gonna
start doing that i used to have dreams
that like i would be like at the park
and like ricky would show up and be like
oh you have a couch like yeah man
i was really into him had a giant poster
he was my guy uh i always hated baseball
i have a good baseball card story
rob you gonna shut it down or should i
tell it
rob did you want to shut it down or are
you gonna take the note it's really it's
really a stolen bike story
and like like most of my store is not a
good store it's going to fizzle out at a
certain point but
[Laughter]
my buddy chris i got a new i got a new
bike it was a red line and which was
like a cool bmx bike i put it together
myself that was the brand yeah redline i
built it it wasn't like a mongoose
redline no the brand was redline yeah i
don't remember that okay
they were like i got it out of a bmx
magazine i like sent away for it i put
all the parts together and i built the
thing which i i didn't build [ __ ] but i
built this jeff pegs on the back uh i
did have yeah i had some pegs on the
back of course all right and so i'm at
my buddy's house and
with and one of my friends chris he's
like hey can i take your bike to the
baseball card store i'm like yeah go
ahead man hops on my bike goes to the
baseball card store comes back hey dude
bad news uh
somebody stole your bike
and i was like he's like i think we saw
them and they like around the corner so
we we got a machete
out of like his garage i can't remember
where we got the machete but we got a
machete i got my machete
and got i'm like you know 11 12. on the
back of like uh some other kids bike on
the pegs rode down in the baseball card
store you know got off looking for the
kids and then got a little nervous that
the cops had seen me with the machete so
i thought yeah i buried the machete and
some leaves so i could find the kids and
then i don't know what the plan was
then go get the machete but uh you know
nothing happened man i didn't get the
bike's gone forever hey if you stole a
red line bicycle in uh
on broadway right outside the baseball
card store and fess up newport rhode
island and uh what probably like 1989
88.
wow there's some machete waiting for you
there's a machete waiting for you buddy
yeah i will track you to bits
have you guys gotten this comment on
your social media where people are like
oh this [ __ ] has gotten too political i
used to love this [ __ ] but it got too
political well
it's always been political you know it's
not that we take a particular stance on
anything as a matter of fact we try not
to we try to kind of skewer both sides
of any argument but the show's always
dealt with politics i mean it's always
always always and i so for those people
who are like it's getting too
politically you should not be political
well this whole episode's about politics
is this the episode where we say uh who
am i going to vote for republicans
yeah yeah it's all one big ass class
yeah yeah yeah that holds up this still
feels the same although i don't think
people feel the same i think people are
more
doug
we could talk about politics we could
actually talk about politics
[Music]
there's another podcast for that there's
other pods
glenn
as host um what's next
i also feel like the host should be like
there's not you know where's my water
glenn
oh well well the host doesn't breathe
you don't go to kimmel and he presents
water for you i think kim would be very
embarrassed if there was no water for me
he would be humiliating but he wouldn't
be the one to bring it why don't you i
brought my water well actually well he
brought your i brought your water yeah
there's only so many hands i had coming
in i had to rely on you rely on other
people yeah i got a question for you
actually um that i that occurred to me
so there's the scene yes yes
there's a scene in the back office where
uh you pull me in the back office and
you try to talk me into do you know
where i'm going with this i like the
scene i don't know where you're going
okay i liked it a lot so you're trying
to talk me into firing frank as the by
the way i do love in this episode also
let me point out that that like how how
qui it's such a rapid it's just rapid
fire betrayal you know what i mean like
literally people get like there's like
seven betrayals in in 20 minutes it's
it's really it's really quite
extraordinary um but
this you're trying to talk me into
firing frank as my campaign manager and
and hiring you as my campaign manager
and you went into this
way of speaking in this rhythm and
everything and if i'm not mistaken
at the time i remember you telling me
that it was sort of inspired by
it was like a not a direct imitation of
but inspired by
uh jack lemmon's performance as shelly
the machine levine yeah in glengarry
glenn ross yeah am i correct am i
remembering that guys i'm like desperate
like ha come on man i gotta eat i gotta
yeah you know i'm older than you like
yeah he's got lots of little threats
yeah by the way threats for those of you
who have not seen glenn gary glenn ross
uh i believe it came out in 1992
amazing film um great play but like they
made a film and it's incredible uh what
other feedback did you get
what do you mean just in general yeah i
don't read a lot i i am pretty good
about not reading a lot
of comments on the internet i like i
like that it's not healthy for me i like
i'm able to
uh take the good and the bad um i i will
say that probably if it was a
preponderance of bad feedback i probably
would stop but most of it's good um so
the occasional bad feedback i actually
really enjoy i think it's really i think
it's really funny and sometimes
i'm like yeah yeah yeah you're right
you're right sure so you can learn a
little i i can learn a little bit from
it did you think emma was right
yes
and and
i did i did i did half right but i
understand hold on a second i gotta
let's
let's relitigate this for a second there
was one particular episode she's
probably commenting on where it did seem
really interesting whatever i think
probably you were gonna say and and you
shut it down but it was it's funny we're
like you told us this story you've told
us this
and i didn't i don't know why i didn't
say this in the moment but i'm like it's
not i'm not telling you i'm acting like
i'm totally thank you
these aren't for you oh i did see yeah i
did say it okay no you've already said
that okay so everybody does this
everything emma's note is your note
every note is your note it's not a good
note it's i mean yeah no it is a guy
it's not that i don't want to hear the
story again i think it's fun to watch i
get it let's not remember things that
way our brains deteriorate the way it is
presented could be misconstrued as you
saying you don't need to tell this story
because i've heard it before
you know it could be misconstrued that
way although i agree i don't think that
is your intention
um
uh
again just a but you know an example of
uh you know rob's tendency to not yes
and but to know why yep no why um
uh did you guys notice did you get well
you didn't because you didn't watch the
episode but charlie did you notice that
you still had the uh the hitler's german
shepherd painting in your in your oh no
i didn't pick up on that yeah yeah yeah
yeah i thought that was i thought that
was kind of fun when did we lose that
after season two
i think what happened was we took a lot
of people were commenting it was it like
destroyed we feel like it was
distracting we were in the editing room
and it was in the background of every
shot
last night
so distracting this stupid german
shepherd painting so we took it down i
think after season two or maybe three i
think we
yeah you know but good on us for like
remembering that when we did the uh and
then we wrote the whole thing for it in
like season eight
i remember you're still i'm thinking of
your story the holocaust hillary's
painting
ridiculous
[Laughter]
i do like episodes where i get to do
some kind of
heightened thing like this one like the
show machine levine or that or uh
the one where i get smart and i have the
cane i don't know why yeah
more of that that's fun but if it was
that all the time it would get old it'd
be goofy it'd be too goofy but it is fun
it's a yeah so we have an ability to
make them all feel different which is
cool but it's not like the same
heightened character over and over and
over that's which is cool yeah
you never know where it comes from you
know
um i i've seen stretch
in this episode so we we talked about
this before but i can't remember if it
made the podcast cut okay okay
and that was that as i recall the first
scene we ever shot with danny devito was
you and danny in the parking garage you
guys disagreed and said that it was
something else but i but let me throw
this out there
i i do remember that the first scene
that caitlyn ever shot with danny
was the scene right before they go into
the comptroller's office to try and
solicit a bribe
you know using uh d trying to you know
suss her up and i think the first scene
they ever shot together that caitlyn
olsen and danny devito ever shot
together was the scene where he's
you know where she says she's stuffed in
she feels like she's stuffed in there
like a jerk or whatever that might be
right yeah that feels right yeah and i
which would mean that that we shot that
and uh hey my brain's working here uh we
shot that at la center studio correct
so the i think the parking garage was
the la center studios parking garage
correct so it it is possible
i do but so was probably the hospital
which is the scene that rob and i think
that's in the lobby which one is the la
center
or two or three
and we also re-shot that scene
yes we did yes we did yes
one of the few things we've re-shot
we've reached out a couple things but
it's rare we thought that was an
important oh [ __ ] right that was the one
that you said was yeah i don't know
maybe but i do
here's what here's why i think the
parking garage team was the first one
and if it wasn't the first it was one of
the first scenes we ever shot with danny
is the
is because i distinctly remember filming
that scene and not being in the scene
and being behind the
you know the monitors
and thinking
that i had a note
to give to danny
and thinking i feel like this you know
i'm this like kid in his 20s like giving
film legend danny devito how do you give
him a note how do you give film legend
danny devito a note like and i didn't
know him that well at that point you
know at that point he was just like the
weird guy who told the teeth and
you know and it's funny like teeth and
watches story he's both
super open to a note or whatever but
depending on who from well that's like
he likes a note from the three of us
he's fine he's like yeah whatever i'll
try this try that but sometimes the
guest director tries to give danny a
note and it's like
no yeah
which is fair it's a test he's got to
know that that that what you're going to
give him is going to make it better or
have the potential to make it better
like and he's now learned after years of
working with us that you know it usually
it's a good note it's worth trying
i remember um fx not loving this episode
i remember
yeah i remember specific feedback which
they were like you know it's
it's good enough obviously and we're not
gonna like not air it but we don't we
don't love this direction for the show
i don't remember specifically why
but i do remember that
uh but you know
uh
maybe maybe because it's it's very sort
of plot driven it's not it's not i mean
it reveals character right because it
reveals like you know you're like my
vanity you know i do love or maybe it's
the same thing that we picked up on
which eventually we were like it doesn't
quite feel right to stay with with the
ancillary characters and yeah maybe it
was that who knows we were still finding
it i mean i think it probably just felt
sillier in some way too because like
instead of the world being crazy we were
presenting characters that were that
were right extreme and the world was we
were kind of stuck in the normal world
and then once you start building that
kind of stuff out then it's not the
world is crazy and it seems like looney
tunes yeah right but then in season
three which we'll get to we got
bonkers oh yeah the characters were the
ones that were blockers not the yeah not
the outside world we were in a little
nutty nuts in season three but uh it was
a lot of fun but i i i do say like i did
really enjoy um
one thing that i think we do continue to
do which i love
is we go very quickly from like ooh
we should one of us should run for
office to solicit a bribe
very quickly to like oh no i think i
could actually win this
to
very quickly you know starting to betray
each other but more more interestingly
enough like focusing on totally the
wrong things you know what i mean
who's gonna get to use the clipboard who
gets to use the clipboard like you know
what i mean like you being like i'm the
campaign manager i get the clipboard you
being like give me the clipboard and
then that's like the thing you said
about the show be coming about the limes
like it became about the clipboard like
yeah and for me it's about the blazer
right do i get do i get to wear a blazer
for this just being excited to wear a
blazer and like being almost entirely
focused on
the fit of the blazer
you know more than
you know soliciting a bribe we're
actually it's like you know and i do
that is something that we have
continuing on the show that i very much
enjoyed there's a funny thing on the
wrong thing funny sound thing that we
did rob uh you won't remember this
because you didn't watch the episode but
um
where you're trying to stop a baby
carriage you want oh yes you want glenn
to kiss this baby you're in a mall and
you should watch it um it's good it's
funny it's pretty good yeah yeah it's
pretty good um
and this woman's like no no thanks i
don't think i want this guy to kiss the
baby and you keep stopping the
the
yeah the baby carriage yeah
stroller yeah
it's been a minute yeah stopping the
stroller with your foot pram and each
time we're adding a nice little
you know okay yeah we added a sound
effect of your foot like
like stopping it each time because there
was no sound in the thing and we just we
found it very funny like you were doing
this funny like little foot turn thing
which is very amusing and it works we
get you know we gotta that was the scene
where uh where i'm doing george bush
hands
yeah right that's this those are really
good george bush hands
bill clinton did that too
this used to be the way that we
communicated with uh the public because
that's right i'm not gonna put my finger
but no typically
that's that that's not um that's no good
that's no good this is this is a strong
people who aren't watching on the video
this when you're saying this
it's like a little thumbs up but not a
full thumbs up right right it's just
like a little pointed thumbnail and it's
not happy it's not yes it's not a point
no no it's not a fit it's not a fist no
no what emphasizes with this the thumb
makes the physique okay the tip of that
thumb
says i'm not scared of this fist and
it's
a thumb
and man you're just pointing the fist at
me and you're saying no i don't know
that was you i mean
so you know that like that was like a
curated gesture yes that was somebody
that somebody said like i want to be
workshopped oh wow yeah somebody was
like was like doing a lot of this and
they were like well this feels like
you're out of control
right this feels like you're angry
this is too accusatory
but if you just do
if you just do the tipia thumb there
this has been studied scientifically if
you just didn't don't say guys you got
to say folks say folks that's that
applies to everyone that's safe don't
say guys and girls and and uh and just
the tip of your thumb they're just a
little tough
to touch them that's a thumbs up okay
get it give yourself a thumbs up
okay you're getting it too high again
there bill
it was bill right who read it first i i
believe clinton was the one i remember
he stole it from bob dole because bob
dole had like a ball
he had like a palsied hand right but he
always had a pen in it yeah he stuck a
pen in there so it looked like it was he
was doing this on purpose yeah yeah yeah
you know bill was like
well gee whiz that is pretty sweet how
he's got that pen in there
uh and they're like bill you can't also
have a penny he's got a pen i should
have a pen and it's what just what about
the tip of your thumb there maybe that's
what if you're doing that but you don't
have a pen you have an invisible pen
that's what it is two invisible pens
this is the direction this is how we'll
communicate with the public two
invisible pens
well what do i do with my dick
what do i pick what about where do i
prefer you keep that to yourself oh
impossible why did i become purely
if you could just keep it in your pants
to four to eight years uh four to eight
years you keep your dick and you've been
48 years
i'd like to see you try that
okay well we're all doing it sir uh oh
my god the president that's true yeah
another another unscripted
uh moment in this episode was uh you
smashing the videotape at the end oh
yeah yeah uh oh and also like the
head the headband
yeah yeah i don't remember whether i
don't remember how that started but i
think it was just in that one take and
it was uh it was very funny to me
i found it very funny when you just go
back to reading your paper and you just
say like yeah because i'm
i'm not doing it whatever very casually
yeah so casual like as casuals could be
like basically telling you that like i
i'm i'm not doing it anymore and i don't
care that it's ruining your life and
that you lost your stupid garbage
to see that and not embarrassed by it or
anything absolutely i haven't seen it so
i won't comment on that when i believe i
believe this this podcast episode has
been fun listen i think
i think
you have to watch it okay because i do
think part of yes getting to the end of
this is that we've have all re-watched
every single episode we've done
and sort of analyzed them and even if
we're not discussing it live in this
thing just watch it because i don't you
know when we get to the end of it we're
like well we watched some of them not
all of them 100 percent rob you're
getting a lot of good feedback from us
today uh about your positive feedback
about your performance on the podcast
and sort of what's expected of you okay
um are you taking questions am i going
to implement are you going to implement
it do you fee are you open to this
feedback are you
uh do you feel as though you're being
dictated to
uh because i know you like to be in
charge
and sometimes you know
you're not
okay so what's the question
are you are you
are you accepting our questions try it
with your thumb oh sorry
are you able to take this feedback and
accept it because how do those thumbs
make you feel
no why
[Music]